you're so scared to get up you're so
scared to tackle four by kind of being a
little bit too too aggressive in that
mid-range he's got to find the whiff
when dishes but oh boy
oh god a little greedy for the slide
you might be paying for it and the wall
kill top 10 worst place to die oh
no he just turned her into a fireball
dude three
wall combo two yeah that one then out i
would complain a little bit harder
oh
running slide that's a minus ten get up
three that's a delay get a three
race drive expended could breathe a
little easier here but steve's still
coming
oh my god
two because we are coming with a jacket
here he knew we were fighting out in the
cold
that's exactly what's up
he could attack roll there but the fact
that he launched but his popcorn
one it's getting crazy
[Music]
yeah
every time mcgill says yeah he's getting
launched
yeah get ready to fly that's me
one two on that down for two
we had a boxing win with the footstop
a jumping footstop by the way
[Music]
[Music]
you